let me start by saying um I love this
movie this movie is incredible I think
you're hearing that from probably
everyone you're talking to
um for both of you you never really know
how a movie's gonna turn out
um so what does it both mean what does
it mean to the two of you to be part of
a movie like this that's arguably one of
the best of the year
um
still haven't really got my head around
it because
um I've sort of only just realized how
like
how much of how much of an honor it is
to be to be part of this because when I
was a lot younger when I first started I
I wasn't I hadn't watched that many
films in my life only like like PG rated
movies so so I think I'm very happy that
that the movie has come out now because
I feel like I'm a lot more mature and
and I've sort of realized how like
incredible it is and how incredible
Guillermo and Mark and and the producers
and the animators are so uh so yeah I'm
just I'm just very happy and honored
yeah I would I would say something very
similar I mean I just I think it's
pretty surreal yeah working on something
and seeing like little storyboards and
stuff like that and then just seeing it
completely
you know finished unbelievable yeah
movie that was just wall to wall
just the best yeah animators and
directors and writers working on it um
and I almost I feel like I played such a
small like I always say to people it's
like I place real like in at least in
the making of it like I play such a
small part in it like the the real you
know actors and everyone of it to me are
like the people that like really like
you know shaped all the characters
physically
um and you know I only went in for a few
sessions and it's like oh sweet now this
movie's out and it's incredible like
that's awesome like I I got to come in
and just like hang out with
the most incredible people
um so yeah I'm just excited about
yeah everyone yeah I'm just excited
about the whole thing the whole movie
when you watch the film there are so
many sequences and moments that you
could just sit and like study because
they're so beautifully done when you
watch the movie is there one or two
sequences in the film that you're just
really Blown Away by yeah the water
um where they're like where they're in
the boat and just just the water around
them I had no idea how they did that
that to me was just like I looked
unbelievable
um
yeah I don't know yeah I on maybe the
second time I watched it because when
you watch a movie again you notice all
the details and I was wondering I was
trying to get I was trying to figure out
what the water actually was so so it was
actually the same as Ben I thought that
was really really cool because it looks
like water but then it doesn't and you
just don't know what it could be yeah it
could be like oil it could be yeah you
have no kind of clue what it is it's
really cool I think that a lot of times
people don't really understand the
recording process and what goes on
behind the scenes so can you for people
that don't realize or don't know how
would you describe like what the
recording process really is especially
the way Guillermo has done it is that he
doesn't want us to act as the character
he wants us to be the character that we
are and I think people people especially
what they said to me um is that it seems
a lot easier but it's really it's not
because
you're just on your own in a booth and
luckily enough I got to work with Finn
on one occasion and David Bradley who
plays your Peta but but for most people
and most of the time you're just in the
booth and you have nothing to bounce off
of so it can be very challenging when
when you have when you have nothing to
direct a line to and you don't have a
costume on or the set the set around you
so
so yeah yeah no yeah I I agree yeah
um
yeah you just you come in and usually
what it is is yeah you record just line
by line it uh and Mark and Guillermo
will be on the other side kind of giving
you notes and then in our case for uh
kind of our like heart to heart scene we
were like in person together which is
awesome and
um just kind of got to run through it
like it was almost live action
um so that was great I've spoken to a
lot of actors that have done uh vo stuff
and they always talk about they dread
when they're doing the efforts like the
grunts I'm so bad at that I I really
that that to me is like hell for me
especially the law thing oh yeah oh I
couldn't I could not I'm a bet you know
some actors are incredible fake laughers
and I can't do it that sounds yeah I
think at some points um it might not be
me laughing or maybe it just is me
laughing but really bad fake laughter
because sometimes I hear it and I just
can't
um yeah it doesn't sound like me but
that that was probably one of the
biggest challenges along the efforts
yeah the efforts for sure are difficult
I think at one point my mom actually
came in the booth to tickle me so so
that I actually did laugh and that
worked I think that's all worked yeah
but I couldn't just stand there and go
yeah yeah that's what I did yeah so
you're ahead of me yeah then I
definitely want to ask you an individual
question
um as I've spoken to you a few times uh
you co-directed a movie co-wrote and
co-directed a movie uh for for people
that aren't familiar with it uh what do
you want to tell people about it or what
can you tease it's a comedy slasher film
um that set at a summer camp and it
takes place at counselors weekend kind
of before the campers get there so all
the counselors are getting the camp
ready and
um yeah people start getting murdered
and it's this kind of Ensemble Camp
comedy with blood in it
um and yeah yeah I wrote you should
watch it I'm excited for you to see it
that'll be awesome I yeah co-wrote and
co-directed it with um Billy brick and
uh yeah we're in the middle of
editing it now so it should be hopefully
someone wants to put it out that'd be
awesome do you have like a plan or have
you guys talked about trying to go for a
festival or do you know what I mean
that's the thought is that we do
something
um but we are past Sundance so you know
you never know uh what could be could be
next my uh last thing for the two of you
um what is it actually
um which of your friends and family uh
this is a weird question but which of
your friends and family were the most
excited hearing that you were a part of
this movie I'm not really sure I think
sometimes my friends that are massive
fans of stranger things uh they're all
jealous of me that I must Finn and
and my dad is a massive fan of just film
in general and a big fan of guilmer so
so he was very excited for me yeah I'd
say my my dad and my brother were my
dad's a gigantic you're my daughter fan
and so is my brother
um and uh yeah they were so excited um
listen I gotta rap I'm just gonna say to
the both of you congrats seriously the
movie is so so awesome I wish you guys
nothing but the best thank you man thank
you